sometimes you don't think they choose
the right man
what what what is it for you what is it
that women in our life yeah see she was
so so you guys said like women don't
always like they might pick future over
the other guy yeah
Paul said you know do you think that the
woman in your life choose the best men
and you said no
what for you then then quantifies or
qualifies the best man if they're
picking who who is it that they're
picking versus what uh versus who you
think they should pick what what are the
distinguishing characteristics in your
own words uh I would say a guy who's
gonna who's gonna provide security for
her emotionally physically and
financially
and the bet the guy who can best do that
all three
in my opinion is the best is the better
choice because the thing is the futures
of the world they're not providing that
emotional security for you probably not
they might provide the physical one if
you're if if you're there but how often
is he gonna be with you like once every
two weeks every two years every two
weeks boy that's like my dreams
um so that's what I would say the one
the one who can do all those three in a
good good standard to be honest
oh
um yeah many what he said like they just
prioritize like um the girl's feelings
emotional security whatnot not too much
on the uh Financial stability wise but
obviously it would be nice if the
financial stable but like the other two
would be more of a priority
um
pretty much the same what they said just
don't know if our ad is
trustworthy like
the things that needs to get done he
gets it done
um I feel like with again you know you
just know you know and we've all said it
here and and so would you say the same
for women then are these also not things
you would want in terms of someone who's
a mo financially stable and and is
emotionally uh intelligent and can be
there for you emotionally and and offer
that stability and who is also
trustworthy would you say that's a
universal thing do you think that's
that's the same for women too no not
exactly well I don't emotional security
yes I don't think guys look to women for
physical security to be honest yeah I
don't think guys look to women for
Financial Security I don't think most
guys do are you saying that men don't
care that I can deadlift a lot
because if you're taller than most guys
they're definitely looking for you to be
physically secure for them
I've seen my bench press it's quite
heavy as well
thank you
I will jump I will jump in here and say
so I was a team GB powerlifter and so I
will say yes like and yeah man but like
it's interesting to see how men react to
that like to do with the strength thing
I think for a lot of guys they're like
yo
really yeah
that makes sense right but um I I think
for it's interesting to see how guys
react to that this is definitely a side
tangent but like it is really
interesting to see how guys react to
that because it's like oh yo you're like
you're strong and [__] you can look
after yourself before that I did Emma um
not Emma I don't think guys really care
do you think I don't know I don't think
I don't think I think they think it's
cool
is it cool to you that I can bench a lot
is it like is it different but I come
from Palestine background and it's but
um I've seen like a lot of my friends
back in like college and whatnot they
were quite skinny and they didn't used
to hit gym and they talk about how or if
a girl had a bit striations or a bit of
muscle automatically they're just
canceled they just look at him and stuff
like that yeah oh wow no I've heard that
too that's like so it depends on the
sort of guy really yeah I think sexual
security you think I think that's
something maybe you guys this guy's just
I just think guys like girls in shape
right
she doesn't have to have like a six-pack
or anything like that like but just a
girl who looks after herself especially
if he looks after himself
do you know what I mean
[Music]
what is the biggest red flags you guys
seeing girls she doesn't offer to pay
her share in the first date he disagree
with you on that
I think it's a great red flag look at it
that's fine
I don't think that's that big of a deal
she doesn't offer to pay on a first date
no because she's not entitled to my time
or my money yeah but sometimes guys just
offer to pay no no no way too foreign
the lack of gesture is a red flag the
lack of gesture yeah because it goes
well sometimes I just feel really
awkward I'm gonna be honest sometimes
I'm like my guy so let's say you see a
girl yeah yeah and you tell and you ask
her to come on a date with you yep you
took her out of her own space I didn't
take her anyway she chose to come I hear
that thank you she was chilling she
wasn't that that wasn't happening like
she Loki wanted him to ask him thank you
she's not gonna she's not gonna say yes
if she doesn't want to come yeah she
wanted to come but she wasn't gonna ask
him so he asked her all right what I'm
saying is is yo you see a girl that you
like yep and you ask her to like can I
please
you don't feel like you she should then
also pay no no I didn't say she should
pay I said she should she should off
here no no she should offer to pay her
share
if I when I if I take if I ask a girl
out on a date
I'm always gonna pay
but I want her to offer to pay her share
this is what I was getting that I was
just making sure that that was the main
thing that you always gonna pay because
you took it out yeah but you just wanted
to see like if she would help out too
it's a lot it's for me it's just showing
it's it's a sign of appreciation she's
like you don't have to do this for me
so I appreciate if when you do
because she the things that she will do
that she doesn't have to do for me but
I'll appreciate like if she I know she
cooks for me it's like it's not I'm not
like oh because you're a woman you have
to do that so I'm like oh thanks babe I
was super thankful and I was like oh
that's so nice like thank you so much
you would still think I was like
entitled
uh
uh because most guys just grab it no if
that's what I'm saying yeah I'm saying
thank you okay by being being
appreciative okay I'm not gonna fight
you for it I won't no but like be like
oh no I don't mind you should spit this
all right no it's okay there you go okay
great thanks but I do
that's still polite yeah that's all
right that's all right okay glad to know
I wouldn't get I wouldn't get sent
packing
I just want to say thank you but like if
she doesn't even say she doesn't odd
friend she doesn't even say thank you I
know the vibe no way I'm taking you out
again I know I know the vibe you're
talking about I get it
my bad it's okay there's always this
happened sorry this happens I I think if
I think though if you if you start to
say that you think that um women should
pay half which by the way I I always
think which is not what I'm saying no no
but I'm saying if you expect a woman to
at least offer even if you say no
um I think then does that not imply that
you also talking back to the
expectations of what you want from a
woman does that then not just say you
don't just want a woman who's pretty and
in shape you now want a woman who is
financially stable because no woman I
think yeah and polite people no but if a
woman wasn't financially stable she
would not offer because if you said yeah
all right and then she's like [__] I've
got no money in my bank account but I
think I think it's the polite would you
agree with like it's because you want
her to be polite yeah I think I think if
I'm being honest I think part of it is